the price of bitcoin on uh christmas eve
i saw you know going back 15 years it's
pretty amazing it's staggering but there
are big swings uh the intra year during
the year we can be up 70 and then we can
go down 50 percent or it has in the past
um
do people that love it want it to keep
being that volatile because they make
these huge gains last year i don't know
what what people made 60 or something or
would it be better if we got
institutional type stability where it
starts being more transactional and
where you could actually start using it
uh
you know to actually use as currency for
example
yeah it's a great question so a couple
of things one volatility is not good or
bad right basically volatility is only
bad when it goes against you so if
you're long an asset it goes down you
don't like volatility if you're long an
asset it goes up you do like volatility
so i think that's kind of point number
one the second is that bitcoin in us
dollar terms has been very volatile
right in the last two years there's been
two separate 50 plus percent drawdowns
this year there's been over six 20 plus
percent drawdown so uh in u.s dollar
terms it's definitely volatile but the
key piece is that that volatility is
measured in dollars so if you think of
the dollar itself the dollar is hyper
volatile as well we just don't think of
that because all of the goods and
services around us are priced in dollars
forty percent of all dollars in
circulation or so have been printed in
the last 18 to 24 months so the dollar
itself has been losing value at an
incredible rate now bitcoin in us dollar
terms is volatile but one bitcoin still
equals one bitcoin if you're simply
buying goods and services priced in
bitcoin i think that that's a key
differentiator between the bitcoin
community and people who still think in
terms of dollars is just what is the
denomination what is that unit of
account that you use i denominate my
entire life in bitcoin when i make a
purchase i think of how much bitcoin am
i spending and so the volatility affects
me much less than if i was thinking
about it us dollar terms